[Music]
hey guys time once again for my tomes of
terror book review show
so the book we're talking about today
was published in 2020 and pretty much
immediately started getting like a [ __ ]
ton of buzz this author's been around
for
a really long time and his books always
kind of like generate a lot of buzz
generally and it ended up winning
several awards
the book i'm talking about is
the only good indians by stephen graham
jones and look again i have a print copy
yes i bought this at barnes and noble
not too long ago
now uh the awards that it ended up
winning in 2020 won the ray bradbury
prize it won the bram stoker award uh
the shirley jackson award and a couple
of other ones as well
now stephen graham jones has written a
[ __ ] ton um you know that's that's a
scientific term i had only read a couple
of his uh i read night of the mannequins
which is a novella and that came out the
same year as this one i think a little
bit earlier uh which i really really
liked i think i i reviewed it on this
series matter of fact uh the other book
of his that i read was actually the last
final girl which came out back in 2012
and i ended up not finishing it because
i just couldn't get into it it was kind
of like a slasher type thing and the
writing style was just kind of like too
much it was kind of yeah so i couldn't
really get into it and i was like well
so i just didn't finish it but i will
say that this book in particular because
it got so much praise i was like well it
you know it kept getting recommended and
everything okay well i really really do
have to
read that it seems like everybody loves
this and i ended up really really liking
it as well i mean i feel like most of
the uh most of the reviews are like
overwhelming overwhelmingly positive but
there are a couple people that just like
didn't like it or didn't get it or
didn't finish it i get that but i ended
up really really liking it although i
will say that i think the first part of
the book is actually a lot stronger and
more entertaining than the second part
of the book but overall i actually
really really did enjoy this
so the novel kind of reads
more like a series of interconnected
novellas
sort of rather than kind of like a
single cohesive narrative like what i
mean by that is there's like a brief
prologue and then there are kind of like
three long sections that follow three
different characters but all the stories
are sort of like centered on the same
series of events like these are all
people that know each other so it's not
like yeah they're completely like
interconnected i will say too that
though there are some absolutely like
brutal scenes in this that are like
really like gory and upsetting and
gruesome
this is pretty much overwhelmingly more
like a slower burn
more
i don't want to say like literary
because people might get to but it is
does have like a literary bent to it and
it's a much more like character based
horror and it's also something like
it also has a lot of black humor to it
which i actually like quite enjoyed and
it's sort of like
aside from being uh you know kind of
like a monster revenge type story it's
also sort of a little bit of a literary
exploration of sort of like guilt and
like uh cultural identity how you can't
escape your escape your past stuff like
that so as i said plot-wise it's
essentially a revenge story uh the
antagonist or the monster or whatever
being a sort of like mythological
creature
who is
righting a wrong that has been done to
her by humans
now i will say that the writing style of
this uh and the kind of like vernacular
that he uses it took me a few pages to
get into it um but after a few pages i
got used to it like i said i kind of
feel like i had the same issue with the
last final girl although he wrote that
in a different style that was just not
like vibing with me this one i think it
was just more getting used to like kind
of catching the wave of like
his narrative voice i guess so
here's what we have so the prologue of
the story as i mentioned earlier kicks
off with a guy named richard boss ribs
or ricky for short
he is uh blackfeet
and he's originally comes from a
reservation i believe is in montana but
he ran off to work on an oil rig in
north dakota after his brother overdosed
he's at this bar one night getting like
pretty epically drunk as one does
and he goes out into the parking lot to
take a leak i guess like the bathrooms
inside are full and he like really
really has to pee so he's like [ __ ]
i'm just gonna go outside and then
there's kind of an altercation where
they're like well you can't come back in
here because there's a big line and he's
like whatever i just need to go out of
pee or whatever so he goes out there to
take a piss in the parking lot
and then he sees some pretty bizarre
[ __ ]
this seemingly crazed elk
kind of staggers into the lot
and starts crashing into a bunch of
these pickup trucks that belong to like
a lot of the good old boys that are
inside so the trucks get all dented up
like all of the car alarms start going
off it's a whole situation
and uh because of the noise like all of
the good old boys inside come piling out
of the bar and they don't actually see
an elk what they see is this lone very
drunk native american man uh kind of
stumbling around in the parking lot amid
all of their damaged vehicles and so
they assume that he's done it in some
kind of rage
so they chase ricky into a field
and he kind of he's running but then he
sees like out ahead of him he sees like
all these glittering eyes and it turns
out it's this big like herd of elk that
are essentially like trapping him or
like hemming him in
so all the white guys from the bar like
pretty much jump on him and essentially
beat him to death
so after this
after this kind of like brief relatively
brief prologue
the story then shifts to another man
named louis a clark
because his parents were apparently
comedians
louis is uh also as you learn from the
same reservation as ricky the two of
them were actually old friends they went
way back
um but he has managed to move away from
it
uh but basically just like uh ricky has
he's married to a white woman named peta
and he has a job with the postal service
and his wife is like an aircraft
marshaler she's like one of the people
that you know
you know guides in the planes with the
lights and everything like that yeah she
does that
um they live like a fairly working class
but a very decent life they have like a
nice house they just uh rented and they
have a dog that they love very much
named harley shortly after though there
appears kind of a wrinkle in all of this
domestic bliss
so there's an indigenous woman named
shaney
who's a co-worker of lewis's
now she's crow and he's black feet and
there's kind of like a long history of
antagonism between their two tribes
but in spite of this uh shaney befriends
him and even seems to kind of low-key
flirt with him at times which he's a
little bit weirded out by but he does
like her like she's a nice lady and the
whole situation though is made like
slightly more awkward by the fact that
all of their
co-workers who are all white they've
kind of got into their head it's like oh
you two are the only indians that work
here like on the staff so therefore you
two are made for each other and should
like go out and they don't really seem
to care that lewis is like already
happily married so there's that
um yeah so it's this big weird thing and
his wife is also just kind of like what
the [ __ ] what is going on with this but
yeah however there is one thing from his
past that lewis has never shared with
his wife
and he ends up telling it to shaney
because he thinks she'll have a better
understanding of sort of like the impact
of it
so it turns out that 10 years prior to
the events of the book when he was just
like an older teenager
lewis and his three friends who included
ricky the guy that was beaten to death
earlier and two other guys named gabriel
cross guns uh gabe for short and cassidy
sees elk uh known as cassidy for short
did something they really shouldn't have
done
so being kind of young and rebellious
and being like whatever [ __ ] it
they deliberately went out into the
reservations elder hunting grounds where
they are absolutely not allowed to go
like only the elders are allowed to hunt
there and i think it's even like toward
the end of the season but they're
absolutely not allowed to hunt there at
all
so
they go to they go there like on the sly
and they go up on this ridge and they
look down into like the valley below and
there's a massive massive herd of elk
down there and they're just kind of like
right for the picking it's like shooting
fish in a barrel and they're super super
excited they're like oh my god think of
all of the elk meat that we will have in
the freezer all winter long we don't
even have to hunt all winter it's like
we'll have everything
so they're like super jazzed so they
basically
end up just shooting into the herd
and they kill nine elk in this big
bloody eruption of gunfire
so they go down to the valley to kind of
retrieve their spoils
and then they discover that one of the
elk a female
isn't quite dead
and they have to end up kind of like
filling her full of more like they shoot
her again and she still doesn't die and
then like they blow her head off and
she's still kind of like kicking and
they're like what the [ __ ] you know what
i mean but finally she does die
um but she i mean she was really real
they're like why the hell were she so
reluctant to die we've never seen that
before but the reason for this uh soon
becomes clear and in that the uh the elk
is pregnant
and was basically fighting for her
baby's survival she was trying to like
curl around her belly while they were
trying to shoot her
now the boys know that it's very it's
too early in the season for her to be
pregnant and yet here it is she's
obviously pregnant
lewis feels absolutely awful about
killing her
and ends up taking out her baby uh and
burying it like trying to respect uh you
know respect the baby and also vows to
her i will use every bit of you like to
honor your legacy or onto your sacrifice
so he wants to do that
now it turns out that when the boys go
back up to the ridge carrying all their
like dragging all their meat or whatever
the game warden uh denny catches them
and basically forces them he's like well
you can't keep that you're not supposed
to be here so you have to throw all the
meat back and he's like basically you're
all banned from like hunting around here
ever again pretty much
so all of the elk deaths ended up being
essentially for nothing it was just like
all a big waste although denny does
concede to let lewis keep the female
like the special one that he killed so
he's like fine just keep it but you have
to throw all the other ones back now for
a long time lewis has seemingly been
able to make good on his promise to use
all of this slaughtered elk like he
basically he butchers her and he puts
all the meat in uh packets and he keeps
some of himself or eats it and then like
or he sells a lot of it to other people
on the reservation and it seems like
that's okay he keeps the hide for
himself and for 10 years his life goes
along just fine
but it so happens or you don't know if
this actually happened or this is maybe
probably what happened and why it took
10 years for this [ __ ] to happen is that
he did sell there was kind of a funny
thing where he sells the meat
to other people in the reservation i
guess there's kind of a thing where you
put like a stamp on it like saying what
kind of meat it is like what kind of
animal it is and the only stamp that he
had available like belonged to um a kid
like his niece or some [ __ ] like that
that was like a raccoon
that was like a raccoon ball so some
people thought it was raccoon meat and
that was like this thing okay so
uh but most of the meat did get used but
apparently 10 years later somebody on
the reservation like after he had
already moved away was cleaning out
their freezer and sees this he's like
what is this like old raccoon meat and
throws it out meaning that he didn't use
all of the elk like he promised to so
this apparently is what sets this
supernatural revenge epic into motion
now after lewis tells shaney all about
this about this elk hunt
weird things start happening around the
house i mean weird things that started
happening before that which is one of
the reasons that he that he told shaney
because he thought she would understand
but like weirdest [ __ ] like ramps up
after that like he starts hearing what
sounds like footsteps or maybe
hooves like creaking on the stairs
outside um he thinks he's like up on a
ladder trying to fix something and he
like peers down through the ceiling fan
like the ceiling fan blades which are
spinning and he thinks he sees the dead
elk like laying on in his living room
and uh so he's starting to like lose his
marbles he's like what the [ __ ] is going
on here
and he starts thinking back to that long
ago el con it's like you know maybe
there's some like bad [ __ ] mojo
coming back to get me
and then most horribly of all so again
like animal cruelty if you really
there's a lot of uh [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happening to animals in this so i'm just
like warning you so most horribly of all
uh his dog harley is stomped to death by
some person or thing in the
garage after this lewis kind of starts
going down this rabbit hole of
you know what could be paranoia or you
know probably not like as you learned
later on
uh he actually first suspects his wife
and then suspects shaney of being sort
of like the agent of vengeance that has
come to sort of like cash in his tab i
guess or like get revenge for this [ __ ]
that he did a long time ago
so this section of the book ends i don't
want to say abruptly but it ends like
really really savagely really gruesomely
and this part was actually like easily
the most entertaining part of the story
and it's also probably like the
grisliest part of the story although
there is some gory [ __ ] happens later on
so after this section of the book ends
we then go back to the reservation
and into the tale of the two remaining
friends that are still alive gabe and
cassidy now neither one of them moved
away from the reservation
and they've established somewhat
satisfying lives within those uh
parameters cassie lives in a cassidy
lives in a trailer with his girlfriend
jolene or joe who is also a crow woman
just like shaney
and the uh the couple are kind of like
saving up money like either to get out
of there to get married or whatever it
is um you know they both have jobs and
[ __ ] like that now gabe is divorced and
he's a little bit of a drunk and a
little bit of a troublemaker but he's
still kind of a good guy but he's
actually really really proud of his
teenage daughter whose name is dinorah
and she is like this amazing basketball
superstar like at the school and
everybody is pretty much convinced that
she's going to
uh get a full scholarship and she's
maybe even gonna like be in the sports
history book someday because she's like
super like supernaturally like awesome
at it right but
again i mean they kind of think after
they hear about uh what happened to
ricky like getting beat up about getting
beat to death outside the bar and what
happened to lewis which i don't really
want to spoil
they're kind of like oh well that's just
kind of like there's a lot of um you
know there's a lot of defeatist kind of
uh you know because life on the
reservation is just so you know
economically depressed and there's like
a lot of uh alcoholism and suicide and
uh drug addiction and things like that
so they've almost kind of like come to
this
come to this impasse where it's like oh
well you know 80 90 of us are gonna die
in horrible ways anyway so what are you
gonna do like you know they die in car
crashes all the time because they're out
doing stupid [ __ ] and so they're they've
almost like come to they almost like
make like gallows humor like jokes about
it so they just think that the two guys
that moved away is just like oh well
they just flipped out or it's like
that's just what happens to people like
us you know what i mean it's just that
kind of thing but it but it so happens i
mean they they've stayed there and they
seem like pretty content with their
lives
but it turns out that uh the
repercussions of that long ago elk hunt
which actually they had jokingly dubbed
the thanksgiving classic because it took
place like the saturday before
thanksgiving i think those repercussions
are about to come due
and so the remaining two guys and their
families as well kind of like fall into
the crosshairs of this
monster essentially um she's like a
shape-shifting kind of horrifying
monster but she's still kind of oddly
sympathetic because you know like the
reasons behind what she's doing
um she's basically called and i'm not
gonna try and pronounce the indigenous
name because i'll just embarrass myself
but basically it translates to
elkheadwomen is what she is
so the only good indians uh it's a book
about many things it's like i said it's
essentially just like a straight revenge
like monster type story
but uh it's also kind of like and
as i said it's not heavy-handed about it
because it does have like a lot of black
humor
but it's kind of like an examination of
sort of like the contradictions i guess
of modern tribal life um seeing how
these sort of like ancient traditions
and these kind of like stereotypical
kind of things that people associate
with living on a reservation clash with
more current ideas of like what what
people actually do there what the
younger people are doing there and it
also kind of talks about how the past
still has this kind of like um like
devastating stranglehold on the present
like the four guys at the center of the
story they're not bad dudes really i
mean they're just regular people
but from the point of view of the
avenging elkhead woman these men were
bad because they essentially visited her
people like the you know the elk with
the same kind of senseless violence that
colonialist forces had always kind of
like marshaled against them against
indigenous people and it's kind of like
repeating the cycle and she's kind of
trying to like you know and she's also a
part of the cycle of violence as well
and it's also kind of like i guess like
an interesting examination of
the cultural identity and sort of like
deflating a lot of the stereotypes uh
surrounding indigenous people in general
and uh blackfeet in particular uh
stephen graham jones by the way the
author is blackfeet himself and how kind
of like growing up on the reservation
has sort of like a profound effect on
your whole entire outlook on life and
how your life turns out even if you try
to escape it so it's very much like a
past impacting the prez like how you
can't really run from your past or
escape from your past type of story but
as i said you don't have to read all of
that deep [ __ ] into it if you don't want
to um because it is on its face just
like a monster revenge story so you can
just read it on that level if you want
to but there's a lot of other stuff
going on uh in there as well so i would
definitely recommend this if you're
interested in more like literary horror
um stories based around you know
indigenous mythologies things like that
um as i mentioned i think the first part
of the book the parts that we're
following ricky and lewis were a lot
stronger a lot more gruesome a lot more
compelling than the later parts were
that followed kind of more like gabe and
cassidy and donora but it's all really
good it's very well written very
visceral very atmospheric
and it's kind of like uh like i said
there's a lot of black humor in it uh
which i really liked because that came
like a lot from the characters about
kind of you know examining their lot in
life and making sort of like jokes about
trying to make the best out of bad
situations and things like that so i
kind of liked that tone of it as well so
overall i thought this was uh pretty
great
and let me know if you've read it i feel
like a lot of people have and i can't
believe it's taken me kind of like i was
i guess this came out almost two years
ago so it took me this long to get i
kept hearing about it hearing about it
i'm like okay well i guess i gotta read
this now because it seems like
everybody's read it but me but uh but
yeah so if you've read it let me know
what you think about it in the comments
or if it sounds interesting to you and
you want to read it let me know that too
and that will do it for this tomes of
terror i will see you guys on the next
one bye